Eh bueno tenemos que que englobar que
han sido distintas
acciones y distintos contextos que se
están conjuntando en este momento en
China justamente desde agosto
aproximadamente ha habido un un repunte
en el número de casos confirmados de
covid Y eso ha provocado que la política
de cero como sabemos ha estado en vigor
ya casi por tres años en China
imponga restricciones en las ciudades en
donde se localiza Incluso un solo caso
de contagios bueno Esto implica la
implementación de medidas receptivas
para la zona en donde se ubican los
casos Entonces más o menos desde agosto
en algunas ciudades se ha visto un
aumento significativo de casos de
considerando que un aumento
significativo para china no es los
mismos términos que en otros países Pero
bueno en el caso de China aunque sea un
solo caso eso implica la imple de
medidas Entonces desde entonces ha
habido varias varias ciudades que han
estado sujetas a estas restricciones y
efectivamente conforme ha ido avanzando
el tiempo esto ha hecho que el
descontento social aumenten
principalmente Porque si vemos que hay
muchas personas que están ya durante
tres años viviendo distintos tipos de
restricciones de movilidad efectivamente
va generando
descontento
si le sumamos
sigue sigue sigue lo escucho claro ahora
si a esto le sumamos que durante este
periodo se llevó a cabo el vigésimo
bueno perdón el 20 de congreso del
partido comunista chino en el que el
siguiente fue reelecto esto también ha
generado un poco de tensiones en algunos
sectores de la población porque Bueno si
fue elegido para un tercer mandato y una
gran concentración de poder se está
viendo reflejada en su figura
le quería preguntar por este tercer
mandato de Pink al frente del partido
comunista no en que se rodeó
precisamente de hombres muy afines no a
su figura Entonces esta afinidad entre
las entre la cúpula del poder en China
evita que haya un contrapeso en la forma
en la que enfocar estas medidas para
frenar la pandemia o ya para
sobrellevarla tres años después de que
estallara
justamente más que más que que se limite
o demás durante el congreso se anunció
que la política se iba a mantener Lo que
sí es importante señalar es que Durante
los últimos meses las medidas sí se han
flexibilizados y las comparamos con las
medidas que se implementaron al inicio y
a la mitad de la pandemia si se han ido
flexibilizando conforme va pasando el
tiempo una porque el gobierno está
preocupado por la producción por
mantener la economía y justamente por
atender estas demandas de la población
si sean flexibilizado sin embargo
evidentemente los las restricciones
siguen vigentes entonces
va a mantenerse la política si
anunciaron durante el congreso que se va
a ir analizando como las medidas se
pueden ir Ajustando a lo que se va
requiriendo en la sociedad y lo que va
requiriendo también que la economía que
vaya funcionando conforme la pandemia se
sigue desarrollando Entonces esto
también ha generado algún punto de
frustración incluso entre la gente
Porque algunos esperaban que durante el
congreso por ejemplo se anunciara que
las medidas se iban a quitar o que muy
pronto se iban a quitar pero lo que se
anunció es que se van a mantener pero sí
se van a ir
Ajustando ahora también hablando justo
del tema de la pandemia y de un tema de
frustración le vamos a sumar un punto
adicional que ha generado que la
población justo en este momento esté
descontada es que estamos viviendo la
celebración por ejemplo del mundial
entonces en China es es impactante por
ejemplo es para ellos ver que en algunos
otros lugares del mundo en este caso por
ejemplo en
Qatar que está el mundial Pues se ve a
grandes pasas de población que están en
temas de festividad que no que no se usa
por ejemplo el cubrebocas que no hay
medidas receptivas cuando en China
estamos viendo todo lo contrario que hay
muchas ciudades en las que efectivamente
están estas restricciones mucha gente no
no puede salir a sus trabajos se
limitaron la movilidad